-Our next guest is a very funny
actor, comedian, and writer
whose work you've seen on
"Detroiters," "Drunk History,"
and right here on "Late Night."
And because she's a writer here,
she wrote this next part
and insisted I read it.
And now, the most beautiful
comedian and writer
I've ever seen, a real live
princess, Amber Ruffin.
-Seth?
-Oh, hi, Amber.
-Seth Meyers?
-Yes, yes, Amber.
-Well, I wasn't expecting a call
from you.
I would have dressed up.
-Oh, Amber.
So that's just your lying around
the house outfit?
-Yes, this is my lounge gown.
-[ Laughs ]
Now, Amber, you've been on
the show many times on camera
over the course of
our 1,000 shows.
This is the first time
I've interviewed you, though.
Are you excited for this moment?
-Yes, it's everything I've ever
dreamed of and more.
You in your weird attic.
Me in my hallway.
-[ Laughs ]
And you know who forced my hand
was Anderson Cooper
because you were on Anderson
Cooper's show last night.
And you were wonderful,
and he's wonderful.
And I was thinking, "Well, now,
now I feel like I have to
interview you."
-Yeah, he appreciates me, Seth.
-[ Laughs ]
I do -- I would like to --
I would like to show a clip of
the end of the interview
where you didn't tell Anderson
you loved him.
You said you "loved him, too."
-Yeah.
-And it really made
Anderson Cooper laugh.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, Amber Ruffin, I'm glad --
I'm so glad you were on tonight
'cause I've been watching
what you've been doing
and I just think it's really
powerful and important.
So thank you.
-I love you, too, Anderson.
-[ Laughs ]
-Amber, we've known each other
for a long time.
We met, because we both worked
for a theater
in Amsterdam called
Boom Chicago.
You were one of the first people
we hired for this show.
But one of the things we found,
I think, having you on camera
and the way you write, is that
you can both talk about
serious things and connect with
people in a way
that also brings them joy.
Did you -- When you first
started doing stuff on camera,
is that something
you knew about yourself?
-No. I thought I was just
going to take this job,
keep my head down,
and not get fired.
Then I found out that you guys
really let people
do whatever they want,
so I got to acting up.
-Well, you know,
we've been really lucky
because we have a writing staff
that, you know, has --
is diverse enough to talk about
a lot of different things.
And things have happened,
particularly the events of
this last month
where, you know, we called you
up and said,
"Hey, do you want to have
something ready for Monday?"
And it was your suggestion
to come on and tell
your real-life experiences
with police.
And initially, you were going to
do it on Monday,
and then you also offered
that you could tell
a different story every day.
What made you think that that
would be the most powerful way
to address it?
-You know, when it started,
I started writing, you know,
bits about the protest, and then
that felt weird and dumb.
But it just became such
an opportunity, you know?
I was like, "Oh, we write jokes
about stuff all the time,
but this is an opportunity
to really let people
know some [bleep]."
Some stuff.
[Bleep]
So I thought, "Oh, let me just
tell a real story,
recount an actual story,"
and then you guys said, "Great.
We'll put it
at the top of the show."
And then the movement
really took off.
And I was like, "Oh, you know,
every day still
feels like yesterday."
You know what I mean?
-Yes.
-It felt that exact same way
for a really long time.
And so I thought, "Well, we --
I've got stories for days.
-And we should point out
that you did four,
and you're not out.
-I'm not out of police stories.
They don't like me.
-And hearing it from someone
like you,
especially someone who has
established yourself
as a person, who when people see
you, they think,
"Well, no one would ever have
a problem with Amber."
-Yeah, people think when police
violence happens, they think,
"Oh, well, what did
that person say?
What did that person do?"
And that gave me a real
superpower here because,
you know, if you watch the show,
maybe you've seen me enough
to come to the conclusion
that I'm a regular dude.
I'm not running around yelling
at people, demanding [bleep].
I'm just hanging out
and giggling, and that happened.
You know?
I mean, can you imagine
if I wanted them to recognize
an ounce of my rights?
You know, which I would have
been able to do.
But I didn't say [bleep].
I complied completely
and that's what happened.
Man, it's crazy out there, Seth.
-It's crazy.
It was awesome to watch them
and we were so lucky to have you
tell us -- I don't know,
share that with us.
And I want to thank you.